hey everyone and welcome back to
Westeros weekly where we are discussing
the penultimate episode of Game of
Thrones Season seven I'm Liana Galera
I'm Ash cross and there was way less
death than we thought last night because
guess who survived this guy Harmon
survived someone very important did not
we're going to get to all of that we're
going to be talking about the fact that
the stark sisters are ready to kill each
other yes they are and there was
obviously a very important moment
involving a dragon so let's kick
everything off with the Nights Watch
catching up on everything important that
happened last night and we got to see
the Seven Samurai or as you call them
snow team six teams Negus is reciting
the army of the Dead and I kept yelling
at my television the entire time because
I thought this was the stupidest plan in
the world
why do you think it was stupid I thought
that it was really creative the way that
they had all these guys stuck the army
of White Walkers is coming to get them
what was your least favorite program I
guess I don't know I loved the episode I
loved everything about it but I just
thought it was a straight-up dumb plan
they just went with seven of them and of
course they're gonna I mean they should
have died they should have done okay I
get what you're saying
so so you're saying they went in they
went to go capture one white and they're
surprised that they encountered the
entire army what were they going to do
you why were they surprised me they
encountered the entire army we've always
seen them all together what were they
what were they going to do really didn't
like follow-up was behind them and just
like grab one and take it I don't
understand what their actual plan was
because it was so frickin stupid I will
say this and I'm about to like upset an
entire fandom I will say that this scene
these whites is what The Walking Dead
wishes they were who I don't think I
said upsetting I think a lot of people
are on your side yeah that's true hoarse
so our guys are trapped and who saves me
a guide but luckily Danny comes to the
rest our Dragon Queen is here coming to
the rescue
this was absolutely epic this was epic
but can we talk about the fact that once
again the season and Game of Thrones
they're completely disregarding time and
space yeah a lot of people are
complaining about that I think that it
was because you know Andrew ran back to
Eastwatch Center Raven the Raven got to
Danny Danny flew in with her dragons
someone on reddit to the breakdown and
said that roughly the guys were waiting
there
about five days for Danny to get there
do you think that that's true and what
do you think the really answer is that
sounds about right because I was in my
head I was like did she get there in
like four hours I don't understand that
doesn't make any sense you're breaking
all the rules
Ashley also made a really great point
when the guys are sitting there and
they're freezing and they go for - why
didn't Barret just light up his fire
sword they're freezing to death
what are the rules of this sort does he
have to be in battle when he is because
he can is lighted up whenever he wants
does he have to be fighting somebody or
can he just use it for a heat source
can you just I don't understand why they
weren't they were freezing to death one
of them died amia floors were soon
minutes since he did have room floor
that's a lot of rules are being broken a
lot of rules are being broken but we've
got to talk about of course the most
gut-wrenching part of this episode I did
cry the night King turns out is an
Olympic javelin thrower and I got four
he's putting up his arm just tossing it
through like let's take a look at this
no lip
[Music]
[Music]
you
Caesarion I cried and can we just talk
about if you guys are wondering why the
night king was able to kill a dragon and
bran was not it's because he went right
for the jugular the fire exploded like
that he's not coming back from that and
I'm sure there's some kind of magical
element involved in there but as upset
as I was to see Viserion die I was
pleased that it was the night king who
was able to kill him
rather than having it be via Cersei
right because that would have just given
her way too much pleasure also I gotta
give it up to Danny for her reaction
here because I thought she they were not
going to be able to even pull her out of
there
oh my god and she Emilia Clarke in this
episode I thought was absolutely amazing
yeah we've definitely seen some acting
progress from her along the show because
she was awesome last night yeah but yeah
she she really like was kind of don't
like you could if he her emotion but she
was able to get out of there he said
cheese I can be aiming in her stomach
yeah exactly
green ah done something else happen
frontal Safari oh my gosh this is by far
the iciest moment of the night maybe
even in the iciest moment of the season
of the series never happier YZ so we
should just go right into the corridor
and into the clip take a look
[Music]
this is effed up huh aft up huh and this
was a fan theory that was floating
around for a while and we finally saw it
come to life we're not life I don't know
come to afterlife come to the afterlife
yeah the night king is his own dragon
his own dragon prediction I think that
Vissarion is now going to emit blue
flames okay we are talking about the
swirls like you see yeah is it gonna be
ice it's gonna be fired
I like your la cool I think our blue
flames here's what I think might happen
I think that now that the night King has
his own dragon he's going to use it on
the wall and use it to melt down the
wall and hopefully that will break the
magic spell and then all the whites can
come into the north I know we still have
bran though we still what is that going
to do
Brian could take over this dragon okay
oh but can you take over a dragon once
it's already been controlled by the
night King because the night King also
kind of has some third-eyed Raven
elements to him I don't know yet
no we don't but that is the only thing
with his whole giving me hope for this
entire scenario is that we still have
bread okay well I would have loved to
seen bran jump into zombie bear last
night can we please talk about the fact
that this is not the only animal that we
saw possessed by the night king can I
have a hot take yeah kind of hated this
thing really yeah I think they were
trying to set up the fact that animals
can become I agree I think that it was a
little bit too much of a foreshadowing
element although it did give them a
chance to show off those amazing fire
swore right I just it stressed me out a
little too much I don't know as a
personal vendetta but it stressed me out
a lot I what other animals would you
like to see yeah I mean we already saw
the horse we they ride the horses we
already know that animals can like I did
not need this need the scene but it's
like not a polar bear fan I guess not
well we did get a huge revelation in
last night's episode we learned well
let's just take a look at cycle let's
let's go right into it go
if you're killing general yeah kill them
all if you kill a white Walker you kill
all the lights that it animated
reanimated I think awesome
that is a big thing because obviously we
see later in the episode that there it's
like let's just go for the night King
yeah because if we kill him
the whole army goes down probably yes
but obviously we've seen that the night
King is impervious to fire he's walked
through it before so killing him is
going to be quite the feat who do you
think that's going to come down to John
oh yeah John probably uh everything's
gonna come down to John and Danny which
leads us into keeping up with Joey
though is so out of tune I was we're not
singers y'all but we are not but we do
see Danny and John hauling in a lot a
little bit was so any closer Danny which
I've been calling her all we've been
cause I'm afraid to say to their it but
she doesn't want hurt him to call her
Danny he doesn't want that no I reminds
her of her brother and probably for
sorry I'm like too soon bro too soon bro
but she does see you know his wounds and
also this was a pivotal scene because
she's like I saw the army it's real yes
I completely believe you it was like
wife will leave you and I believe in you
and then he did this let's take a look
[Music]
now about my queen
then
then the name until hit 150 is open to
see you for what you are
[Music]
[Music]
Oh would you date someone that said it
if you John Snowden yeah that's what I'm
saying well running gag of the show is
that John is short John is short he's
not that sure I'm sure what he lacks in
height he makes up her and heroism
exactly um I really did love that moment
I love that I'm starting to feel that
they both are really feeling each other
and I don't care if they're related I'm
here for it
dying I thought that it was really
important that Danny shared with John
that she can't have children she said
like this area and the rest of her
dragons they are the only children that
she'll ever have so I thought it was a
nice subtle way of kind of being like
hey before we really commit to this you
should know I'm barren okay but so here
is my question yes if Danny cannot have
children who is going to take who is
right sir exactly the whole theme of
this episode because Gary and asks are
very carefully my girls don't I you have
no one to take your son and I don't
maybe we don't know if she will she got
so upset with him but like obviously he
only has her best interest at heart
almost seemed like she was threatened by
him asking her that I think it also puts
her in a kind of an emotional vulnerable
place so she doesn't want to be in fact
that she can't yeah or she thinks she
cannot leave and no way I'm what are you
doing I'm getting Stark sister update
right now know what why now yeah they're
gonna kill each other
tensions are running high at Winterfell
between the stark sisters and here's an
interesting thing is that I am team
salsa I am team Arya so we are also a
little divided today we see this scroll
confrontation go down and Arya I don't
know to me Ari is just not listening to
her and it's driving me crazy and I
understand what sounds I was doing but
look at it from arias point of view Arya
has been put through hell not saying
that Santa hasn't but so when she sees
the scroll she looked you betrayed our
family it doesn't matter I thought it
was really interesting when she said
what did Cersei put a knife up to your
throat I thought it like she really just
called out Sansa because she was a naive
little girl she was but we I saw stuff
to me like Lyanna Mormont okay
what like she she wasn't thrust into
this world by mistake she like servants
was more of a reluctant hero she didn't
want any of this shouldn't want the
first up I got now here she is
lady of Winterfell making decisions
realizing she's great at it okay we've
really seen her kind of grow into this
role
I don't think throwing Lyanna Mormont in
her face is helping because that's a
completely different storyline so but
from arias point of view she was always
raised knowing she could not do what the
boys were doing and knowing that like it
was going against all the customs and
everything that her father had told them
even though he kind of secretly
supported her shooting the arrow and
everything but now she's seen Sansa who
never wanted all this asking as the
ruler of Winterfell not even only the
lady of Winterfell and really acting as
this she's taken over like a guys
position I really think that Arya is
feeling a little bit jealous of the fact
that yes she reluctantly did not want
this but now she's so good at it I just
think I think consuls making smart
decisions I just think that she no she's
not she's listening to Littlefinger is
she though where she I don't know let's
find out I could even become
[Music]
wonderful we feel a way to others pretty
trances
to be the lady of Winterfell
all I need right now your face
can I borrow your face there is
something more to this because I
understand that Ariane saans I have
never gotten along but it's in I die
this is just some next-level stuff I
think there's something else beyond them
just not getting along I'm glad I think
that Game of Thrones is giving us a
deeper meaning behind two sisters
squabbling yeah I don't think they would
cry I would hope I would hope they
wouldn't just I would hope that Sansa is
smart enough to read into the fact that
our is basically saying I can take
anyone's face and become that person and
no one would know ie I could cut off
little finger space we would still have
control of the veil and you would not
lose any of control because that's the
important thing for keeping Littlefinger
around is the fact that they do have the
veil behind them exactly so yeah I like
this I think Sansa it maybe it's just up
to Sansa to kill Littlefinger and then
in Judea done then she could prove to
Arya that hey yes because what was
interesting I'm not at the pawn I know
what I'm doing yeah and it has to be
with the cat's paw dagger because what I
liked was that Littlefinger gave it to
bran or to bran to try and gain his
trust bran
rejected Littlefinger David - Arya Arya
is now rejecting Littlefinger and is
giving it to Sansa it's up to her to
finally be the last stark to turn on
Littlefinger and aren't after we're safe
until the bail and everything is great
sisters get along again yes um but
here's the thing do you think that she
sent Brean away for eons own safety I
don't know I you you surfaced me earlier
and it's like what is Brienne need
protecting from I think to get out of
little fingers way because obviously
Littlefinger wants to turn Brienne
against Arya and wants them to fight it
out right and wants to eliminate brand
from the situation so rather than having
Littlefinger do it himself
I think Sansa sent her away in order to
protect her yeah I don't think she was
just being a baby because obviously
Littlefinger was trying to get in her
head referencing Brienne and then all of
a sudden Sansa sends her away there's
something more to that I would hope that
Sansa just really cares about Brandon
because bran has done everything for her
yeah bran has the best she's the best it
was the best like torment
I want her internment to make babies hmm
I'm fine I might be a little team
Brienne and Jaime because I just wanted
to get away from Season one
would turn one to offer yourself I want
our mom to be single as a Pringle ready
for me let's take a look at the race to
the iron throne where everybody is
standing right now so we have John and
Danny together yeah because they are
killing it
they're killing a finely teamed up John
has a been metaphorically bent benita
they are a team now and Cersei doesn't
have a lot behind her she and she knows
that she doesn't have a leg to stand on
and she knows that her dragon killing
scorpion did not work which is going to
make everything very interesting next
week hmm
should we take a look yeah at the
preview let's do it
episode
[Music]
[Music]
there is only one wall that matters and
it is here this is something we have
been waiting for since the beginning of
the show just everybody coming together
in one place queen meet Queen I think
it's going to be amazing
what do you think's going to happen and
I agree with Danny that and Tyrion that
Cersei is planning some kind of a trap
I'm really worried because they're on
her turf there in King's Landing I'm
just thinking about Pat like in past
seasons the second to last episode if
something crazy happened then the last
episode kind of wraps everything up
which makes me think that nobody is
going to die did you know anyone's gonna
die I just I don't know I we haven't
really had that many significant deaths
this year so I feel like this is going
to be the episode where it happens each
week we're like asking me Clara oh it's
going to be torment I made you cry but I
really feel like this is going to be the
episodes that we're going to lose
someone and it's going to be someone of
significance I'm going to point to our
off-screen producer Mike here who thinks
that there we're going to get that cool
gimbal which is a big fan theory of the
mountain in the Hound having a showdown
one of them dying if the Hound dies I
would be ok with it because I feel like
his character arc has been so
transformative because he really
redeemed himself because he looked after
Sansa so many times he protected Arya in
this last episode he really saved John
but no I really feel like if he has to
go he's had such a redeeming arc that
it's fine i 100% agree with you yeah
yeah he's like the unofficial start
Guardian unofficial start Guardian I
like it here's what I want to know from
you guys since we are so divided
are you team Arya or are you team Sansa
T nationally our team Liam shucks them
in the comments below or you can of
course tweet us and tell us all of your
season 7 finale series because we're
dying to know what happens one note you
guys are thinking can be our last
episode of Westeros weeklies to come
back with us we should have had wine we
should have red wine at 8:00 in the
morning on Monday that sounds good to me
hey Dan somewhere get him to work thanks
so much guys for stopping by I'm Liana
Galera I'm ash Krause and we're gonna go
watch the solar eclipse